Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus kleine Kunstpause
hast du hast mich gehört ja ich habe
dich gehört aber du bist noch ganz
versunken kontemplativ unterwegs
gelegentlich denke ich nach aber ich
werde mich bemühen das in der nächsten
Stunde nichts zu tun weißt du was immer
noch mein mein
Lieblingssatz von dir ist jemals hier in
einer Folge gesprochen und der Satz der
mich immer wieder selber so zum
Nachdenken bringt ist dein Satz über
deine Kindheit dass du damals gesagt auf
meine Frage wie war denn eigentlich
deine Kindheit dass du so auch so wie
jetzt so eine Kunstpause gemacht und
sagtest na ja das war eine sehr stille
Kindheit ja ja
also ich habe mich sehr früh in der
Kunst trainiert meine Gedanken zu
bringen ja aber das ist auch einfach in
einem turbulenten Elternhaus ziemlich
wichtig wie meinst du na ja wir waren ja
zwölf Kinder ja meine Mutter war jetzt
nicht das was man sich so unter einer
mütterlichen Mutter vorstellt und das
bedeutet dass bei uns so sag mal der
Wärme gerade gering war und der
auseinandersetzungsgrad ausgesprochen
hoch okay das heißt einen bestimmten
Alter wenn man drei Geschwister im
gleichen Alter hat was ja bei mir so ist
und die alle in der Pubertät sind dann
kann man sich vorstellen wie tumultartig
das bei uns zu Hause vorsichtig okay
okay also ich habe nicht so eine stille
Berg Kindheit vormacht wie du ja ich
muss dir mal die Stille suchen du musst
es nur aus dem Haus gehen und es
verstellen ja das ist wahr das heißt die
einzige Wärme die du hattest den Stern
durch die Reibung mit deinen
Geschwistern ja
oder die warmen Gedanken die man hatte
wenn man in seine Welten abgetaucht ja
ich habe mir immer Paradise im Kopf
geschaffen das wird mich interessieren
weil das habe ich auch gemacht wo warst
du unterwegs gedanklich was war der
Traum na ja also ich hatte erst mal ganz
ganz viele Interessen als Kind ne also
ich hatte den kleines Aquarium aber
meine Fantasien über dieses Aquarium
gegen Unendlich über das Aquarium hinaus
also das war schon jetzt viel zu dicht
gefüllt mit Fischen und das war zum
Beispiel eine Welt ich gehör auch in
diese nerdwelt der Briefmarkensammlung
also ich war unendlich begabterin immer
wieder neue anordnungs- und ordnungs-
und umordnungssysteme für Briefmarken zu
entwerfen das war auch eine Welt in der
ich mich viel aufgehalten habe
Geschichte machen großes Thema was mich
interessiert hat ich habe häufig so
innere Dialoge seit Hörspiele wenn ich
aufgeräumt habe im Kopf gemacht gefällt
historische Situationen variiert deine
lieblingssituation ja zum Beispiel wenn
ich das interessant dass ja als England
von den normalen überfallen wurde ja im
Jahre 10666 ja William the der der
William und vorher waren ja die Norweger
und mit Harald harderer da ebenfalls da
gelandet hat ja war das ein Zufall oder
war das irgendwie verabredet
und hadra da ist ja dann verdroschen
worden an der SAM von Bridge und dann
sind die völlig desolaten
zurückkehrenden Leute von Harald dann
auf Venom der oberhocker getroffen und
haben das verloren und ich mir immer
gedacht habe war das eine konzertierte
Aktion und wenn wie sind die Wikinger
dafür entschädigt worden so das ist
einfach nur blöder Quatsch ja ich habe
mich nie wieder in meinem Leben damit
beschäftigt aber so als Zwölfjährige
habe ich mir das immer alles ausgemalt
wie das Ding gewesen sein könnte und so
weiter also ich würde mal sagen ja wenn
nichts aus mir geworden wäre hätte ich
vielleicht Drehbuchautor bei Game of
Thrones wird
wunderbar und auf welches westenseite
warst du was du eher bei William dem
Eroberer der ja glaube ich Winzer Castle
glaube ich das war doch sein Schloss
dass der Kassel gab es noch nicht
irgendwie mit angefangen auf ihre
ehrlich ich meine Jahre wir gewinnen
ist es achten oder noch später gewesen
wir checken das mal okay ich sehe Lukas
der Typ schon also ich weiß andere
bedeuten die Dinge
sehr fortschrittlich damalige Zeit okay
ja also das war das überhaupt so eine
rechts-system
etabliert wurden was auch
niedergeschrieben wurde also es geht
sehr viele kulturelle Errungenschaften
und sozusagen Englands Größe beginnt
eigentlich erst bei wieder mit richtig
richtig
vom Pferd gefallen und von seinem
eigenen Pferd zertrampelt nein und das
ist also sicher ja faktisch gesichert
das ist glaube ich ziemlich gut faktisch
gesichert okay
gerade zu überlegt irgendwie was das
eigentlich für eine schöne unschuldige
Zeit war ne auch so in unserem Leben und
so 10 11 Jahre alt bist ich habe das
auch so erlebt du fängst dann an dich so
zu versenken in in Bücher ich habe auch
diese die klassischen sagen des oder die
großen sagen das klassischen Altertums
gewesen und so weiter diese ganzen Dinge
Karl May gelesen wieso ich bin auch
immer ich bin immer abgehauen deswegen
war mein Traum also gedanklich mein
Traum war immer
irgendwann mal nach Kalifornien
auszuwandern das war für mich so das
große Versprechen und als ich dann
irgendwann ist dahin geschafft habe ich
bin glaube ich mit 26 Jahren das erste
Mal überhaupt geflogen und ich weiß noch
ich saß in diesem Flugzeug und tat so
als wäre ich natürlich ein mega
erfahrener etablierter Flieger ich
wollte nicht peinlich auffallen wusste
aber nicht wie man diesen
Sicherheitsgurt schließt haha
vorsichtig nach links und rechts geguckt
und habe genau mir angesehen wie die das
machen und als ich dann das erste Mal
über den großen Teich geflogen bin und
das erste Mal in Kalifornien war dachte
ich ja genauso habe ich mir das
irgendwie vorgestellt da kann ich nicht
enttäuscht worden also man sagt ja immer
kein Sex hält was die unanie verspricht
also die die Fantasien die man sich von
etwas macht und dann wird man mit der
Realität konfrontiert sind ist die
Messlatte natürlich hoch also was
begeistert das ist auch ein schönes Wort
in dem Zusammenhang aber egal ja ich
mochte das ich mochte das ich habe ähm
bis heute bin ich fasziniert und
abgestoßen zugleich ja also du siehst
einerseits dieses soziale Elend an an
vielen Stellen du siehst diese
glitzertürme speziell in San Francisco
und dem Schatten dieser Türme die
Obdachlosen Zelte und so weiter wirklich
mit mit Blick auf den auf den Facebook
Tower und so
aber gleichzeitig ich mag diese Art
sozusagen das Leben zu begreifen die
Leichtigkeit die das Leben dann doch
immer noch da hat er hat der Ozean das
Licht was wolltest du in Kalifornien
werden
Musik produziert ja immer Produzent
werden ja ich wollte Musikproduzent
werden hast du dann da Kontakte geknüpft
nein ich hatte ja einfach nur ein großes
Vorbild das war George Oma oder der der
dann später südtiroleranz von mir der
der drei Oscars bekommen hat weil er
unter anderem Top Gun ja take my Bretter
way und diese ganzen Sachen das hat er
alles geschrieben und das war halt so
die die große Inspiration weil der ist
ähnlich gemacht hat ne der hat
angefangen als auch als Hotel als
barbianist und ist dann irgendwie
gelegentlich als es dann so langsam
losgehen und er irgendwas werden wollte
ist er danach München hat dann dort
irgendwelche Studios angemietet hatte
dermaßen keine Kohle dass er im Auto
übernachtet hat und dann wurde er
irgendwann donnersamer kennen und und
hat dann love to love you baby gemacht
und so weiter diese und dann dieses
berühmte stöhnlied wenn du dich
erinnerst ja wo sie wo sie über Minuten
so vor sich hin stöhnt weil du gerade
über
sexuelle Dinge gesprochen hast und dass
das war sozusagen dann der große Skandal
und hat ihm sehr geholfen und dann ist
er war auch mit Harold Faltermeier ne
der heute ja noch aktiv ist auch ganz
toller Typ der gerade wieder für Top Gun
am Start war das war alles so diese
Clique und die sind dann gemeinsam quasi
nach Los Angeles und haben noch mal ein
zweites Mal alles auf eine Karte gesetzt
wie man die Waren in München etablierte
Leute und haben dann noch mal alles auf
eine Karte gesetzt und haben gesagt okay
pass auf jetzt Amerika und dann haben
sie Amerika gemacht und das hattest Du
als Fantasie als Junge ja und das Ding
und das Ding war weil wir gerade über
München sprechen
ich bin dann irgendwann auch nach
München und dann war die große Frage und
und da kommt jetzt sozusagen die Brücke
ins Hier und Jetzt ich habe in München
gelebt dann im Kolpingheim das war ich
war sehr dankbar für diese Unterkunft
aber es war echt also sehr einfach und
am Karlsplatz am Stachus ja und habe da
in so einer in so einem winzigen Zimmer
mit zwei anderen noch irgendwie vor mich
hingehaucht und hat immer wahnsinnig ein
Respekt vor der Frage wie findet man
jetzt in dieser fremden Stadt für mich
war München eine riesige Stadt ja ich
meine ich komme aus einem Dorf mit 350
Menschen
wie findet man deine Wohnung wie findet
man sich zu Recht und da denke ich
manchmal heute die die uns noch viele
junge Leute zuvor Internetseite ja aber
aber heute Handy ja da aber irgendwie
gings wir haben uns irgendwie
durchgeschlagen und so weiter heute
fehlen
700.000 Wohnungen ja also junge Menschen
die heute auf Wohnungssuche sind Leute
wahnsinnig die kreative aber auch
Pflegekräfte auch sogar gut verdienende
wenn jetzt in München unterwegs bist die
finden keine Wohnungen mehr du hast
keine Chance und einer der Hauptgründe
dafür ist das Thema es fehlen Handwerker
ja das ist die verkennst du jemanden
hast du einen und ich frage mich
manchmal wie konnte es passieren dass
ausgerechnet dieses Land das doch dieses
duale System hat das so großen Wert
immer gelegt hat auf Ingenieurskunst auf
Handwerkskunst dass wir jetzt in einer
Situation sind in der eigen keiner will
mehr Handwerker werden und uns fehlen
diese Leute an allen Ecken und Enden und
wir wissen dass auch alles seit vielen
Jahren und irgendwie wird immer
schlimmer als eine Katastrophe hast du
eine Antwort darauf aufrecht hat
ja also ich würde mal sagen wir haben
zwar das Handwerk immer so ein Fest
treten gelobt Handwerk hat goldenen
Boden so und so weiter und das gute
deutsche Handwerk aber wir haben
gleichzeitig ein Bildungssystem dass das
Handwerk verachtet das muss man in
dieser Deutlichkeit sagen also diese
Gedanke seid die Angestellten Kaste
entstand Angestellte flächendeckende
Angestellte gibt es seit 20 Jahren
dann entsteht der Stehkragen Proletarier
genau da entstehen die Massen Büros die
riesigen riesigen Büros damals natürlich
noch mit mit Schreibmaschinen und
registratoren und was ist alles in 20
Buchhalter ja da gab es ein riesen Boom
an der entsteht eine neue customer die
Angestellten Kaste die zum Teil nicht
besser bezahlt ist als die Arbeiter die
aber den dunkel hat sich die Hände nicht
schmutzig zu machen
im englischen unterscheidet man ja die
blue color worker ne die sich die Hände
schmutzig machen die Blaumann von den
white color Workern den Angestellten
richtig und seitdem gibt es quasi den
kollektiven aufstiegsraum ja also vom
blauen Kragen zum weißen Kragen stellt
eine Verbesserung da
und also
ja also gar nicht mal real sozusagen mit
der Realität sehr wenig zu tun das kann
man relativ leicht daran erkennen wie
viele Handwerker haben ein Burnout ja
und wie viel Euro Angestellte also von
Handwerker mit Burnout habe ich sehr
sehr selten gehört gibt es aber auch ne
mag es möglicherweise geben aber wenn
man guckt was sind so die Berufsgruppen
wo die Burnouts am größten sind dann
hast du die die die die die den
klassischen white color worker bis
Informatiker
die haben gefährdetesten für Burnout
sind und so
Verwaltungsangestellte auch mittleren
Ebenen und so weiter da sind ist die die
Quote sehr sehr hoch weil es vielleicht
häufig so ist dass man bei der
Büroarbeit
in unbefriedigteres Erlebnis hat als
wenn man etwas herstellt etwas
praktiziert etwas macht worauf man stolz
ist also diese diese Angst vor der
ewigen Wiederkehr des sinnlosen gleichen
die es unter den white color Workern
sicherlich zu Recht
ausgeprägter es gibt Leute die ganz
glücklich in dem Beruf sind wo alles gut
ist aber es geht eben auch viele
unglückliche in dem Beruf und ich glaube
so ganz viele unglückliche Handwerker
gibt es eigentlich nicht also unter
reine glücksökonomie betrachtet ne ist
diese Notwendigkeit lieber white color
als blue color worker zu sein nicht
darstellbar aber es war der der Traum
vom sozialen Aufstieg Handwerk war immer
irgendwie mit mit Unterschicht in
Verbindung gebracht die Macht von
Arbeiter ja und Angestellter das war
eben was besseres und das
charakterisiert die Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik und ein Bildungssystem
das seit Ende oder seit Anfang der 60er
Jahre
ausgelöst durch das Buch von Georg Picht
ja Georg pichtweide wahrscheinlich der
einflussreichste Philosoph in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik wegen der
Folgen seines Tuns also nicht weil er
jetzt so eine ganz große akademische
Nummer war Philosoph von Theologe
sondern weil er im Buch geschrieben hat
das heißt sie hieß die deutsche
Bildungskatastrophe und da vorgerechnet
hat dass wir in Zukunft unglaublich
viele Akademiker in Deutschland brauchen
in erst in die Ingenieure aber auch
Juristen und und und und und und dass
wir die alle nicht produzieren weil wir
zum damaligen Zeitpunkt nur ein
Abiturientenquote von 10% hatten und das
sind viel zu wenig
und für ihn war wichtig dass eben auch
Frauen eine Chance kriegen Abitur zu
machen und dass wir also da war der
Traum dass wir vielleicht 20 30 40
Prozent von Abiturienten haben von denen
dann viele eben auch studieren sollten
und das hat die Wirtschaft begierig
aufgegriffen das haben sie eingesehen ja
dann war auch immer die Rede von wir
sind auf dem Weg in die
Dienstleistungsgesellschaft und das
wurde massiv gefördert und im gleichen
Maße verschwanden Fächer wie Werken aus
der Grundschule ja und das war alles
wurde akademisiert die einfachsten Dinge
das ist ja bis heute so es gibt
Studiengänge für Dinge wo man sich immer
wieder den Kopf darüber schüttelt wie
man sowas überhaupt akademisieren kann
wo man sagt das sind Dinge die muss man
in der Erfahrung oder in der Praxis
lernen nein da gibt es so allem
irgendwie ganz große Theorie und vor
wissenschaftlich rum und so und das
jetzt quasi in dieser Zeit ein und
parallel dazu wurde der Handwerker Image
mäßig abgewehrt und wenn eine
Gesellschaft sich das leistet ja etwas
super dienstvolles und notwendiges für
die Gesellschaft die Handwerk über
Jahrzehnte zu werden imagemäßig habt ihr
nur Handwerker dann darf man sich auch
nicht wundern wenn es keiner mehr werden
es ist verrückt ne wenn du die Situation
jetzt anschaust ich meine auch die die
aktuelle Koalition die Ampelkoalition
die Regierung ja also jeder erzählt dir
auch bei uns in der Sendung wir brauchen
Zuzug ja wir brauchen endlich die
berühmten Fachkräfte und so weiter und
dann denke ich immer ja gut okay also
unbenommen ist es so dass wir Menschen
brauchen ganz zwingend aber wo wohnen
die dann da müssen wir den gleichzeitig
suchen was auf also wenn ihr kommt ja
dann zählte mit boah gerade sagen dann
müsst ihr entweder Zelten oder oder
irgendwas anderes machen weil so richtig
unterbringen können wir euch nicht äh
dieses Ziel auch 400.000 neue Wohnungen
zu bauen ja vergiss es funktioniert
nicht ihr müsst Zelten oder pendeln ja
und zwar auf verstopften Straßen ja und
den Zügen den ich nicht fahren dann
durch die Gegend pendeln weil zum
Beispiel gerade die Sonne scheint oder
im Winter ist oder irgendwas ist halt
immer das heißt wir sind als als Land
wenn du dir das mal anschaust wir haben
nicht nur keine Handwerker uns fehlt
aber also auch für den Fall dass die
Leute kommen wir sind ja
infrastrukturell überhaupt nicht darauf
vorbereitet
das stimmt also wir haben da über
Jahrzehnte etwas schleifen lassen in
dessen Ursprung in der Missachtung des
Handwerks und der arbeitsberufe liegt ja
und dieser dieses Versprechen der
aufstiegsgesellschaft hieß dass er dann
irgendwann Akademiker wirst ob der dafür
geeignet wirst ob du glücklich bist ganz
ganz andere Frage
und ich persönlich mir ist das alles
ganz ganz spooky also wenn ich sehe wie
Eltern ihre Kinder durchs abiturprügeln
mit tausendfach Nachhilfe hier und da
und so weiter hauptsache die schaffen
das irgendwo und auf Internat schicken
damit sie das schaffen ich kann nur den
Kopf darüber schütteln also ich denke
immer lieber ein glücklicher
Fliesenleger als ein unglücklicher
Professor richtig ja und abgesehen davon
steckt da diese diese implizite
Abwertung handwerklicher Leistung ja ist
eigentlich nur Unverschämtheit also ich
persönlich habe den größten Respekt vor
Dingen wo ich selber nicht gut bin
wo ich immer denke mal wie macht man das
wie kann man das und so weiter in meinem
Leben im Blut gedrungen die eine oder
andere handwerkliche Tätigkeit selbst
gemacht habe glaube ich das auch
beurteilen zu können und hat ein riesen
Respekt vor solchen Leistungen ich habe
als ich als Student bin ich ja in eine
völlig verwahrloste Wohnung gezogen ich
habe das glaube ich schon mal erzählt
und diese diese Restaurierung oder
Renovierung davon war ja work and
progress ich hatte überhaupt keine
Ahnung davon also ich habe also selbst
auf diesem Weg alles falsch gemacht was
man falsch machen kann ja gut das waren
jetzt nicht die die ganz schweren Sachen
dabei muss keine Wasserrohre verlegen
oder
abfallrohre oder ich habe auch die
Elektrizität da nicht verlegt aber alles
andere gemacht also die Sachen wie
putzen und lackieren und eine Ecke mit
Fliesen ausgestattet wo der Ofen warm
oder solche Sachen so ich will auch
nicht sagen es war unglaublich stolz
drauf ja obwohl das dilette Leistung war
aber dieses schöne Gefühl mit seinen
Händen irgendwas geschaffen zu haben ja
gesagt konnte ich dann stundenlang drum
rumtanzen und wahnsinnig stolz auf mich
sein wenn ich danach arbeite in der Uni
geschrieben hat was hat man am Ende in
der Hand ja 20 Seiten Papier mit
Schreibmaschine geschrieben also die
Sinnlichkeit die in diesem
Erfolgserlebnis etwas hier gestellt zu
haben etwas gemacht zu haben und so
weiter liegt die ist bei so
kopfarbeitern teilt die sicher
eigentlich nicht mit und ich finde das
bis heute übrigens wunderbaren Ausgleich
zu den anderen Tätigkeiten und ich habe
einen großen Respekt an kennst du diese
die Kampagne die das Handwerk gerade
gestartet hat ist halbe Land ist ja
zugepflastert gewesen zwischenzeitlich
ein letzten Sommer war das glaube ich
mit mit Plakaten des Handwerks und eine
Anzeige einen Plakat ist mir besonders
in Erinnerung geblieben da siehst du
eine junge Frau und die sagt was gegen
Handwerk spricht meine Akademiker Eltern
da ist eine Menge dran da ist eine Menge
dran und ich ich ich habe mich oft
gefragt was hat das eigentlich dieser
Mangel an Handwerkern an Nachwuchs im
Handwerk was hat das zu tun mit diesen
deutschen Bildungssystem ich glaube eine
Menge wenn ich mir auch so im Umfeld das
ansehe wie ich früh eigentlich schon
dieser also wie fast sagen Terror los
geht dass man wirklich Kinder dann
wirklich unter Druck setzen sagt pass
auf du brauchst jetzt unbedingt diese
Empfehlung fürs Gymnasium und so weiter
also da denke ich manchmal dass das muss
das müssen wir noch mal grundlegend
hinterfragen ich komme aus einem Land
ich habe das erst hier erfahren das war
für mich das von dem ich Staunen stand
ich komme aus einem Land da gibt es das
nicht also ob ich aufs Gymnasium gehe
oder nicht diese Entscheidung habe ich
ganz alleine getroffen da da gibt's kein
Lehrer in Italien der dir sagt du pass
auf du darfst und du darfst nicht in
meiner Kindheit war das auch nicht so
als ich die Grundschule verlassen habe
konnten ihre Eltern das frei entscheiden
so und der Punkt ist ja und das ist das
was ich nicht verstehe das ist ja
eigentlich fast schon ein Anschlag
sozusagen auf das Menschsein jeder
einzelne von uns ist so wie er ist und
jedes Kind ist so wie es ist und jeder
hat so seinen ganz eigenen Rhythmus ich
meine wenn wir uns mal selber in unserem
eigenen Leben so umschauen wie viele
Leute kennst du die in der Grundschule
irgendwie so mehr schlecht als recht
irgendwie mitgekommen sind
und wie unglaublich gut wurden die dann
plötzlich irgendwann im Verlaufe der
nächsten vier fünf sechs vielleicht auch
zehn Jahre oder wie erfolgreich wurden
sie später als Unternehmer oder was auch
immer eben also auch viele die die in
Gymnasium schlecht waren ja genau es war
nicht so dass die Klassen besten bei uns
die so so Fantasie Abitur gemacht haben
von 0,8 oder so dass die am Ende da die
steilsten Karrieren gemacht hat das
meine ich und und einfach nur so dieses
also dieses Menschenbild das da dahinter
steckt so nach dem Motto das können wir
jetzt alles normieren und das legen wir
dann genau fest und du gehst auf
Gymnasium und du aber dann bitte nicht
denke dass das geht doch völlig an an
der Lebenswirklichkeit vorbei und es ist
es ist ehrlich gesagt ja wirklich ein
Anschlag auf jeden Fall Kindern
Liberalismus ne wir haben ja beim
letzten Mal Liberalismus gesprochen ja
also mir gefällt das alles nicht die
drei Teilung der Schulen ist nicht
besonders förderlich für das ganze
System und die ganze Ausrichtung war so
für den für den Bedarf der
Bundesrepublik gemacht wo man eben wie
Pech da meinte wir brauchen unglaublich
viele Akademiker
und heute ist es eben umgekehrt wir
brauchen auch nach wie vor viele
Akademiker weil wir brauchen auch ganz
ganz viel anderes und wenn man mal
aufhören würde in der Schule eine solche
Missachtung gegenüber dem menschlichen
Körper zu zeigen wie man das macht ich
weiß das sind große Worte aber ich meine
das sehr ernst wenn ich an die
Grundschulzeit meines Sohnes mich
erinnere der kam von der Schule nach
Hause und ist eine Stunde lang auf dem
Bett rumgehüpft weil der dieses still
sitzen ja also für ein Kind ja ich weiß
nicht ob beim jungen noch mehr als zwei
Mädchen
keine artgerechte Haltung ist ja also
man braucht tobräume ja aber für die
Schule ist der Körper nur dafür da den
Kopf von einem Klassenzimmer ins andere
zu tragen das ist leibfeindlich ja
dieses System ist komplett leibfeindlich
dieses System widerspricht unsere
Einsicht dass wir wissen dass es ein
Engel Zusammenhang zwischen Lernenden
und körperlicher Bewegung richtig ja das
wird überhaupt komplett dafür gibt es
Sportunterricht da wird eigenes Fach
draus gemacht aber eigentlich also ich
zum Beispiel wenn ich auswendig lerne
was ich in meinem Leben ja häufiger
gemacht habe dann gehe ich also ich bin
in meiner Studentenzeit in Köln immer um
den Aachener Weiher umgegangen ja also
das ist der typisch oder oder man macht
so wie die die Rabbiner so wippende
Bewegung mit dem Kopf und so weiter also
für mich ist das sind absoluter
körperlicher Vorgang das zu tun und das
sind alles Dinge wenn man jetzt in der
Schulbank sitzen würde und würde wie so
ein Rabbiner die ganze Zeit mit dem Kopf
runter wenn man sofort denken da gibt es
eine Störung ne und da musste
Ergotherapeut angerufen werden oder
Ritalin verabreicht oder wie auch immer
genau ich war ein Kind in der Schule Gel
bis heute nur eine Lösung Ritalin ja
würde man sofort sagen der muss gedimmt
werden ja ich war entweder bin ich
abgetaucht und ich war überhaupt
aufmerksam und das ist überhaupt
Prognose erstellen
das heißt der Umgang gehen die Schule
mit der Körperlichkeit fliegt das wird
der Körper wird als als als Störung des
reibungslosen Unterrichts betrachtet ja
und ich meine handwerkliche Fähigkeiten
werden aus dieser Körperlichkeit heraus
entstehen die werden die rausgebogen ist
richtig und eine körperfeindliche Schule
bringt eben entsprechend keine Menschen
hervor deren körperliche Fähigkeiten
besonders trainiert werden ja mir geht's
immer noch mal dieser Begriff von von
von Rhythmus jeder von uns hat doch
seine eigenen Rhythmus in meine der
berühmte Knoten der aufgeht der geht
doch nicht bei allen gleich auf nicht
bei allen am Beginn der ersten oder
nicht an Beginn der zweiten und auch
nicht am Beginn der dritten Klasse
vielleicht bei dem einen in der ersten
Klasse vielleicht beim anderen erst in
der fünften das weiß man doch nicht und
und da ist aber dann die Entscheidung wo
du dann hingehst wo deine eigentliche
Begabung ist wo deine Interessen liegen
wo deine Begeisterungsfähigkeit liegt
die Entscheidung ist dann bereits
getroffen und das das
daran finde ich es andere haben sie für
dich getroffen nicht du ja gut die
schlimmstenfalls treffen ist sowieso die
Eltern die Entscheidung aber man kann
immer noch hoffen ob im Sinne des Kindes
das war ja auch bei mir so also wenn ihr
gerade wie gut ich in der Grundschule
war meine Eltern gemeint hätten nicht
sollte nicht aufs Gymnasium ja da wäre
ich ja nicht aufs Gymnasium gegangen das
liegt ja dann doch in der
Verfügungsgewalt der Eltern das stimmt
aber ich habe neulich einen sehr guten
Text von von Arno Frank gelesen toller
spiegelautor der der sagte was wir da
gemacht haben ist wir haben einen
Schulsystem konzipiert als soziale
siegregationsmaschine in der alles
andere als Gymnasium und Abitur als
scheitern verbucht wird und das stimmt
ja das ist so und das ist ein riesiges
Problem also ich habe ja häufig genug
auch in meinem Buch gewittert gegen das
dreigliedrige Schulsystem
und das einzige was für das 3gliedrige
Schulsystem spricht ist dass die
Gesamtschulen die die Sozialdemokraten
in den 60er 70ern konzipiert haben noch
schlechter waren das spricht aber nicht
gegen das Prinzip Gesamtschule wenn man
lernen individualisieren würde könnte
man funktionierende Gesamtschulen machen
man kann aber nicht eine Gesamtschule
machen und das klassische lernen und
Fächersystem was es bisher gibt
übernehmen das führt im Regelfall dazu
ausnahmen bestätigen diese Regel dass
die Gesamtschulen schlechter sind als
die Gymnasium und das deswegen besonders
ambitionierte Eltern ihre Kinder nicht
auf Gesamtschulen schicken es gibt da
Ausnahmen gibt doch berühmte
Gesamtschulen und der vorbildliche aber
es ist eben ziemlich flächendeckend so
gewesen das heißt das war eine
halbherzige Reform die am Ende nach
hinten losgegangen ist aber warum man
Kinder im Alter von 10 Jahren bereits in
eine Schublade steckt die Hauptschule
Realschule und Gymnasium das ist
natürlich grundpfe falsch und
interessanterweise ist das auch nur in
Deutschland so und die sehr sehr wenigen
anderen
abzählen wenn es überhaupt diese
Trennung gibt dann gibt es die so im
französischen System z.B nach dem
sechsten Schuljahr
oder das viel bessere System wie zum
Beispiel Skandinavien in Dänemark ist
das so dann gehen alle im nach wie vor
die Volksschule und die die abmachen
also die gehen dann machen dann extra
sozusagen diese letzten zwei drei Jahre
und das ist ein ziemlich gutes System
aber das will man bei uns nicht weil man
dann denkt ja aber dann werden die nicht
richtig gefördert wenn alle in die
gleiche Klasse und so weiter und uns ist
ja so das Skandinavien nicht gerade
berühmt dafür ist dass das Schulsystem
schlecht ist oder dass die
Bildungsprobleme haben
es ist aber so es setzt voraus dass du
eine relativ fette ronomische
Schülerschaft hast
dänemark ist ein Land mit wenig Reichtum
und noch weniger Armut das heißt also
ein fast reines mittelschichtsland
und da ist das natürlich sehr viel
einfacher weil die Voraussetzungen vom
Elternhaus und vom Umfeld ziemlich
gleich sind das ist natürlich jetzt wenn
man in einem Stadtteil lebt wo auf der
einen Seite den willenviertel ist und
auf der anderen Seite ein Problembezirk
ne dann stellt sich die Frage an das und
die die größte Voraussetzung um
einheitliche Schulen zu schaffen ist
uneinheitliches lernen also nicht alle
müssen im selben Alter im selben Tempo
das gleiche lernen letzter Punkt das
wäre die Voraussetzung das ist ja
sowieso die zentrale Forderung die man
bei einer man kann das ja nicht mehr
Reformen nennen sondern bei einer
Bildungsrevolution bräuchte
meine Handwerk wann ist das eigentlich
entstanden sozusagen so diese diese
klassische Zunft des Handwerkers der ja
mal so enorm wichtig war der heute
wieder unglaublich wichtig ist ich meine
wenn Robert habe gesagt wir müssen jetzt
alles auf Wärmepumpen umstellen dann
denke ich immer das ist gut und schön
aber die abgesehen von der Frage woher
diese ganzen Wärmepumpen kommen sollen
die muss ja auch jemand produzieren ist
ja die Frage wer sie dir dann einbaut
und da merkst du plötzlich wie so ein
System das sozusagen immer darauf gepolt
war Probleme einfach mit Geld zu lösen
ja wenn irgendwo ein Problem auftaucht
dann ist der erste Reflex okay kommt
dann zwei Milliarden oder drei oder vier
und dann geht das Problem weg dann lösen
wir das subventionieren was auch immer
und jetzt kommen wir das erste Mal an
der in dem Punkt an an so eine Klippe wo
wir feststellen okay das mit der mit der
mit dem vielen Geld das funktioniert
nicht mehr
Haarwerk sitzt auf Fördertöpfen im
Milliarden höher um und das Geld wird
gerade mal so kleckerweise abgerufen ja
weil dir schlicht die Leute fehlen das
umzusetzen und da merkst du plötzlich so
ein ganzes System wird völlig
dysfunktional weil das was Politik dann
an Ideen und Ordnung vorgibt und dann
Weg vorgibt das könnte man theoretisch
beschreiten aber praktisch geht's nicht
mehr weil die schlicht die hier ausgehen
mir ist ja der Mentalitätswechsel in der
Bevölkerung eigentlich schon ganz gut
fortgeschritten also du kannst hier die
die coolsten Liebster am Prenzlauer Berg
angucken ja die wenn man sie fragt was
machst du beruflich sagen Projekte ja wo
ich immer nicht weiß ja sind das jetzt
erfolgreiche Virtual Reality Designer
oder leben die vom Geld ihrer Eltern
aber was machen ihre Freizeit die sitzen
auf ihre begrünten Dachterrasse züchten
Bienen ja und Schlachten selbst also
dieses ehrliches Handwerk machen zurück
zur Natur ja unmittelbarer Kontakt mit
der Natur das sind ja ganz große Themen
ja das ist aber so das macht man
freiwillig so man würde nicht mehr den
Begriff dafür benutzen aber es macht man
halt nicht beruflich weil das Berufs
Image ja zu schlecht ist richtig ja weil
man sagt ich bin nicht Metzger von Beruf
ja sondern ich schlafe da als Hobby ja
das ist ein großer Unterschied ist
übrigens kein Witz mit dem Schlachten
ist gerade ziemlich in selbst schlafen
selbst Hühner auf Wasserschlachten und
so ja auch weniger zusammen
ganz große Nummer wobei ich nicht weiß
ob es die archaische Tätigkeit ist also
das Ausweiten was da Mittelpunkt steht
oder ob es das soziale Schmierfett für
den Aufstieg in die entsprechende
Gesellschaftsschicht ist das müsste man
mal auseinanderhalten aber eigentlich
ist das sozusagen zu erkennen dass gute
Arbeit mit den Händen einen großen Wert
darstellt ich glaube so weit sind wir
inzwischen wieder ja und sei es über
einen zweiten oder dritten Bildungsweg
das ist da aber nach wie vor ist dieses
an dieses Kreuz geschlagen zu sein du
bist nur Handwerker was du aus der DNA
der Bundesrepublik kommt das müsste
überwunden werden ich meine ich habe
eine ganz positive Prognose
gesagt ich glaube dass das alles sehr
gut für das Handwerk laufen wird ich
glaube das wird sich alles ändern durch
die Digitalisierung
weil die Digitalisierung unser long run
eben dann schon irgendwann dazu führen
wird dass er viele white color-arbeit
verschwindet wir hatten über Chat
gesprochen also ein schönes Beispiel
dafür ist weil das ist ja nun schon
ziemlich gut und ziemlich erfolgreich
und kann eigentlich auch schon einiges
ersetzen und auch in vielen anderen
Bereichen ist die Technik da nur die
Implementierung der Technik von die
kommerziell oder ökonomisch erfolgreiche
Implementierung der Technik dauert halt
viele Jahre aber das wird schon dazu
führen dass in Banken in Versicherung in
den Verwaltungen langfristig deutlich
weniger Menschen gebraucht werden
und dem gleichen Maße wie diese Berufe
das sind ja die Berufe die die Kinder
der Handwerker ab den 70er 80er Jahren
erlernt haben wenn die deutlich weniger
werden und gesellschaftlich an Bedeutung
verlieren wird im gleichen Ausmaß das
Handwerk wieder an Bedeutung
zurückgewinnen damit ich ziemlich sicher
und das würde mich sehr freuen ja ich
ich also die Frage ist ja warum soll
jemand der schlau der her redet
wertvoller sein als jemand der einen
Stromkabel verlegt ne das ist das was
was was Anne Frank der an diesem Text
auch meine Meinung ja genau aber und und
wenn du sagst einerseits
alle an der Uni und an den Universitäten
zum Teil auch Menschen und man sagt ist
vielleicht gar nicht der richtige der
perfekte Platz für dich auf der anderen
Seite diese diese Sehnsucht der Bienen
züchten selber Schlachten und so weiter
ich habe aber trotzdem das Gefühl den
Wahrheit ist das eine Attitüde ja und in
diesem in diesem Kontrast wird das cool
also du bist du bist
wissen was das so beweisen muss dass du
als Allrounder nicht nur programmieren
sondern auch Schlachten kannst das ist
hast du vielleicht ein Attitüde aber das
ist überhaupt sein Einzug in diese Welt
gefunden hat ist nicht ganz
uninteressant das ist wahr aber die die
Bereitschaft ne ich ich sehe das immer
an Handwerkern die Disziplin die da dazu
gehört ja in morgens früh aufzustehen
dann auf diese zugige kalte Baustelle zu
gehen ja wenn wenn die Hütte irgendwann
fertig ist dann ist ja alles schön und
gut aber auf dem Weg dahin musst du sehr
sehr hart im Nehmen sein ja das muss man
auch alles wirklich wollen dann sind die
viel viel unterwegs ja auf Baustellen
Südtiroler Handwerker sind unglaublich
gefragt weil durch den Buben im
Tourismus hat sich da einen ein
gewaltiges Know-how entwickelt ja
Handwerker zu sein ist in Südtirol etwas
was ein hohen Stellenwert hat was das
angeht eine ganz andere Gesellschaft
wird verdienen auch gutes Geld die Leute
und und hat dann ganz anderen Stellen
gegenwärts in dieser Gesellschaft aber
wenn Du Dir mal anschaust zum Beispiel
Bundestag wir haben den größten
Bundestag aller Zeiten 736 Abgeordnete
schätze mal wie viel davon sind haben
ich weiß
15 15 so 15 ja also total
unterrepräsentiert wir haben ja sowieso
erschreckende repräsentationslücken im
Bundestag ne wir haben völlig
überrepräsentierte Berufsgruppen wie
Lehrer und Juristen und Handwerker
sträflich vernachlässigt in dem System
ich glaube tatsächlich wir hätten eine
ganz andere Bildungspolitik wenn die
Quote der Handwerker im Bundestag auch
nur halbwegs dementsprechend würde was
sie zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt beitragen
nämlich um die 10 %. ja überleg mal also
es gibt da Hagen Reinhold von der von
der FDP der ist glaube ich Maurer und
betonbauermeister dann habe ich mich mal
mit Tina von der AFD darüber unterhalten
der ist auch kommt auch aus dem Handwerk
hat ein Handwerksbetrieb entweder hatte
oder hat er immer noch und dann wenn ich
mich halt los glaube ich war Müller wenn
ich das richtig im Kopf habe der der CSU
Mann Peter Ramsauer war glaube ich auch
gelernter Müller ist auch ganz
interessant dann gibt es noch Jens
Köppen von der CDU das Elektromeister
und so weiter aber du kennst die letzten
Endes alle weil sie eine so seltene
Spezies sind
und das erzählt halt auch so viel finde
ich über die die Wertschätzung ne jetzt
könnte man natürlich sagen guter
Handwerker hat keine Zeit im parlam
nur ein Lehrer hat die Zeit dafür oder
ein verkrachter Jurist das ist auch
nicht so einfach ja ein Handwerksbetrieb
und eine Tätigkeit als Parlamentarier
miteinander zu vereinbaren das muss man
sagen natürlich auch schon mal schwierig
also arbeiten und regieren ist zusammen
eine steile Kombination das ist wahr
welcher welchen Einfluss hat also diese
Krise verschärft sich ne wir haben wir
haben im letzten Jahr haben wir glaube
ich gerade mal sowas um die
290.000 Wohnungen gebaut 2021 ja 22
wissen wir glaube ich noch gar nicht
also keine 300.000 wir müssten
mindestens 400 000 schaffen das
Verrückte ist dass ein guter Teil dieser
290.000 Wohnungen man denkt mal ist ja
eine stattliche Zahl was da an Wohnungen
gebaut wird aber das sind sozusagen so
neoklassizistische Sprossenfenster geölt
der Eiche Habitate für nicht nur
vermögende sondern sehr sehr vermögende
reiche Leute für irgendwelche
arbeitsnormalen für Leute die sagen muss
man
immobilienportfolie noch mal ein
bisschen erweitern ja und die eine
dritte Wohnung brauchen weil sie
vergessen haben wo ihre Zweitwohnung
eigentlich liegt das heißt die Illusion
die da in dieser Zahl mit drin ist ja
wir lösen den Wohnungsmangel das ist
eine Illusion dass das gaukelt etwas vor
was so in Wahrheit gar nicht ist
wo kriegst du die Leute her die in
Zukunft diese Wohnungen bauen mir ist
das ein völliges Rätsel und ich frage
mir auch in dem Zusammenhang Rente mit
63 zum Beispiel ein
spd-projekt Andrea Nahles hat das damals
durchgesetzt war das nicht ein
Riesenfehler das so zu machen einfach so
pauschal da so drüber zu gehen gefällt
mir ja sowieso nicht da dran ja also ich
mag ja sowieso diese Pauschalregelung
alle nicht ne ich kann doch die
umgekehrten Fall sagen weil die
Professoren die versucht haben sich
einzuklagen weil sie mit 65 in Rente
geschickt werden auf dem Höhepunkt ihres
Schaffens also grundsätzlich ist diese
diese diese klare Festlegung von
Altersgrenzen eigentlich auch nicht mehr
aktuell das wird mal allgemein dazu
sagen aber die Rente mit 63
ist jetzt nicht der für den
handwerkermangel weil es gibt auch sehr
erfolgreiche Handwerksbetriebe wo der
Chef ja und vielleicht auch der ein oder
andere angestellt deutlich länger
arbeitet weil er das will also da sehe
ich eigentlich nicht das größte Problem
was versteht also ich glaube wir
brauchen einen fundamentale Aufwertung
des Images des Handwerks verstärkt durch
die Digitalisierung die zu einer
Abwertung von geistiger Routinearbeit
fährt und das Ziel ist das Handwerk
davon profitieren will und für eine
lange Übergangszeit werden wir ohne
Zuzug diesen Bedarf nicht decken können
man muss ja auch mal sagen was
Deutschland fehlt sind ohne Zweifel sehr
viele Menschen in Handwerksberufen aber
wir haben nicht nur ein Fachkräfte mal
wir haben einen Arbeitskräftemangel wir
haben ja auch nicht genug Servicekräfte
in der Gastronomie ja was ist denn mit
all den Leuten wenn wir jetzt wir werden
ja in Zukunft gigantische
Infrastrukturprojekte dadurch machen
dass wir unsere ganzen Autobahn sanieren
müssen das ist ja das wird sicherlich
wenigstens 20 30 Jahre wird ja in
Deutschland sich in einer einzige
Baustelle verwandeln weil diese ganzen
Sachen die in 60 gebaut sind eine marode
sind da braucht man ja auf der einen
Seite hoch quantifizierte Leute haben
wir brauchen Leute die relativ einfache
Tätigkeiten richtig es fehlt aber an
allen Enden und es ist nicht als ob die
einen da wären und die anderen nicht
sind alle nicht da ist richtig und
nochmal dieser
Fachkräftemangel nochmal Rente mit 63
wenn Du Dir mal die die Eckdaten davon
anguckst es ist schon wirklich irre also
ungefähr
290.000
sind im Jahr 2021 in Rente mit 63
gegangen das war ein Drittel aller neuen
Altersrentner und man muss natürlich
davon ausgehen dass sie ohne dieses
Angebot natürlich länger gearbeitet
hätten das heißt das ist so Ihre Firma
sie hätte länger haben wollen ja Markus
unterschätzt man nicht in meinem
Bekanntenkreis ist wirklich erstaunlich
wer in meinem Alter und zum Jünger in
Rente geht
weil ihn die Firmen Angebote machen die
sie nicht ablehnen wollen
also es gehört ja auch dazu dass man
jemand der über 63 ist für diese Arbeit
auch weiterhin beschäftigen will und da
gibt es sehr sehr viele Fälle wo das
überhaupt nicht der Fall ist also
überall da wo ich was jung jungen
dynamischer digitalisierter und so
weiter es ist man wahnsinnig froh wenn
man die Leute lieber noch vor 63 los
wird also diese Dynamik gibt es ja auch
außerdem ist das so jemand der 63 ist
der eine ziemlich hohe Gefahr dass er
auch ziemlich häufig krank ist und dass
er nicht da ist und vielleicht ist was
seine Arbeitsleistung nicht mehr die
gleiche bei aller Erfahrungen die er
dann hat wie ein junger Mensch den man
schlechter bezahlen kann der aber bereit
ist mir zu tun der Idee nach gibt
natürlich auch viele junge Leute die
nicht so wahnsinnig motiviert sind und
so ne und das sind so die
abwägungsprozesse liegen genau im Laufen
aber insgesamt sind natürlich die die
Bezahlung der der älteren Leute im
Regelfall sehr sehr viel besser und
deswegen wollen viele Firmen Sie auch
einfach loswerden es ist verrückt ich
ich weiß noch als das Projekt Rente mit
63 jetzt völlig anekdotisch aber
sehr sehr prägend ich weiß das kam und
dann gab es im heute journal damals
einen großen Bericht darüber und dann
wurde mal gefragt was die Leute dann so
Vorhaben ja und von politischer Seite
wurde ja immer der arme Dachdecker und
so weiter ja und wir wollen sie
ernsthafter Lanz dass Leute noch mit 63
Jahren irgendwo auf dem Dach stehen die
Wahrheit ist diejenigen die nicht mehr
können die wirklichen genau solchen
strapaziösen Berufen unterwegs sind
Handwerksberufen der berühmte Dachdecker
der geht ja schon viel früher ein Rente
der ist meistens schon Mitte 50 gar
nicht mehr in der Lage diesen diesen
wirklich harten Beruf wirklich
genau das heißt die betrifft das
eigentlich gar nicht und ich fühlte mich
damals Feuerherz von genau von diesem
Gefühl dass das irgendwie nicht passt
und dass man da immer sozusagen auf der
einen Seite so eine so eine so eine
große Erzählung aufbaut ja so eine so
eine mitleidige Erzählung gerade von
Seiten der SPD dass das irgendwie nicht
so richtig zusammenpasst als ich diesen
Beitrag im heute schon heißer da wurde
ein Mann der mit 63 jetzt also in Rente
gehen wollte diese Frührente annehmen
wollte gefragt was das denn jetzt vorhat
und ich dachte die Antwort ist nicht ich
muss mich erstmal ausruhen ich bin jetzt
wirklich fix und fertig und er sagte ja
ich mache das ich finde das wirklich gut
weil jetzt kann ich mich endlich in Ruhe
auf meinen Triathlon vorbereiten
fertig ist doch ihre wir können auch
nicht jemanden der in der Lage ist in
Triathlon zu laufen das war ein ganz
dynamischer fittermann ja den können wir
noch
das können wir noch nicht machen und
natürlich ist das seine freie
Entscheidung und natürlich neben die
Leute das auch aber angesichts von
Fachkräftemangel und angesichts der
Tatsache dass wir wirklich jede Hand im
Moment so gut gebrauchen jeder
Gesellschafter Ansprüche schneller als
die Ökonomie ist zulässt also die
Tendenz dass man immer eher in Ruhestand
geht ist unaufhaltsam die kann man auch
nicht mit Gewalt zurückdrehen das glaube
ich überhaupt nicht ja früher haben die
Leute in Bismarck Zeiten haben sie Rente
erst mit über 70 gekriegt und meistens
waren sowieso vorher tot und dass wir
jetzt in eine Welt kommen die Leute
später in den Beruf gehen und früher
rausgehen ist er eigentlich erstmal eine
segensreiche entwickeln ja für jeden
Einzelnen ob das der Zustand den wir
zurzeit haben also der Zustand sowohl
von allgemeinen Arbeitskräfte Mangel wie
spezifischen Fachkräfte mal ob der
dauerhaft anhält so dass wir gezwungen
sind die Gesetze rückgängig zu machen
oder ob es eine Übergangsphase ist in
einer ökonomischen Revolution das was
ich vorhin beschrieben habe also dass
die wir quasi den Markt umsortieren das
sind zu viele Leute in Verwaltung
Versicherung Banken und so weiter und so
weiter haben und zu wenige Leute in
anderen Bereichen dass wir die Ökonomen
das nennen ein mismatch haben und das
ist ja irgendwann sein könnte wenn in
dem einen Bereich Kräfte freigesetzt
werden das in einem anderen Bereich dann
wieder mehr zur Verfügung stehen das
geht nicht eins zu eins ne also wer wer
aufhört bei der Sparkasse muss nicht
unbedingt Lust haben Altenpfleger zu
werden oder morgen Fliesen zu leben oder
morgen fliegen ne so wird das nicht
aufgeben aber es könnte unser long run
aufgehen also es könnte über die
Jahrzehnte veränderte Bildungspolitik
und so weiter könnte das Aufgeben so
dass ich glaube der Schlüssel wird am
Ende nicht liegen an der an der
Rentenzahlung zu drehen sondern der
Schlüssel wird daran liegen rechtzeitig
die Weichen zu stellen für eine sich
diesbezüglich veränderte Gesellschaft
und zum Schluss gefragt Richard wenn wir
danach Lösungen suchen kurzfristig
mittelfristig was kann man tun es
Stichwort Schulsystem was würdest du
anders machen ja also ich habe das ja
vorhin gesagt ich würde
einheitliches Schulsystem machen und auf
diesen Blödsinn Hauptschule Realschule
Gymnasium verzichten aber unter völlig
anderen Bedingungen als das heutige
Gesamtschulen tun also ein starker
individualisierten Unterricht machen
projektgebundenen Unterricht und so
weiter und schon oft drum und halten wir
haben ja auch schon mal Bildung geredet
und ich glaube dass in die Kinder
rechtzeitig und Jugendlichen die
Möglichkeit haben ihren Neigungen
entsprechend in der Schule unterrichtet
zu werden dass das ein großer
Unterschied ist und jetzt kommt was ganz
wichtiges
die Leute die die
sich für Automotoren interessieren in
der Schule da gibt es ja wirklich viele
die müssen davon einem leibhaftigen
Kfz-Mechatroniker unterrichtet werden
die ganzen Handwerksberufe müssten in
den Schulen vertreten sein ja irgendwann
kennt die ja gar nicht wirklich das war
was was hat man denn für also für eine
Kenntnis man kennt vielleicht den Namen
diese dieser Berufe aber das was könnte
vieles sein ja also ein ganz breite
Palette also wenn ich jetzt ein
Handwerksberufe gemacht hätte dann
werden zwei in Frage kommen und ich
hatte keinen Berührungspunkt damit in
der Schule oder sonst wo also ich wäre
entweder Buchbinder geworden
ich liebe das ich lasse ja meine alten
Bücher einbinden und ich diese dieser
Geruch allein dieser Papiere und so
weiter das ist eine Welt in der ich mich
sinnlich völlig zu Hause fühle okay ganz
akkurate Präzisionsarbeit ne die auch
teuer ist so gut bezahlt ist Prägungen
ne Gold Gold
wunderbare Einwände zu gestalten
und Schriften da rein zu machen und
hoffentlich großartig und ich wäre
Gärtner geworden ne ich bin ja
leidenschaftlicher Hobbygärtner und
liebe das total also nicht den ganzen
Tag gepflanzt habe und gestutzt und
alles das gemacht mit um dekoriert dann
bin ich glücklich
obwohl ich die Schattenseiten des
gärtnerberufs bestens kenne weil ich ja
mal auf einer Baumschule gearbeitet habe
und da die ganzen Tag Fichten
ausgegraben ich weiß also was für eine
furchtbare Knochenarbeit was sein kann
trotzdem sind das sind das Dinge die ich
mag so kam das in der Schule vor hatten
wir die Möglichkeit gehabt zur Gärtnern
war da ein ein leibhaftiger Gärtner der
uns erklärt hat wie man wie man Pflanzen
wie man Bäume richtig schneidet und so
weiter kann nicht vor hätten in meiner
Schule die Gelegenheit gehabt dass wir
Bücher einbinden lernen hätte ich das
wahnsinnig gerne gemacht und wie viele
die das dann machen und da positive
Erfahrungen machen und dann plötzlich
das Gefühl haben sie machen was
sinnvolleres oder was was Sie besser
können als in Matheunterricht ja ja
werden doch darüber überhaupt erst daran
geführt richtig und das heißt also die
mangelnde Präsenz das heißt in den
Schulen die Inspiration
das wiederum nicht aber daran dass der
Unterricht so organisiert ist ne was man
in der Schule durchnimmt ist ja nicht
Fähigkeiten zu trainieren sondern Stoff
abzuarbeiten richtig ja
und Reinhard Karl einer der größten
Bildungsexperten in diesem Land sagt
immer den Stoff sollte mir den Dealern
überlassen
das was du sagst leuchtet mir vollkommen
ein wenn du mal überlegst was sagen
Kinder auf die Frage was möchtest du mal
werden
die die sagen doch nicht ich werde
Informatiker oder was auch immer diesen
nennen die meistens handwerkliche Berufe
das heißt da gibt es ja offenkundig eine
Faszination
da gibt es eine Faszination die werden
die werden alles mögliche die werden
auch Piloten und keine Ahnung was alles
aber die die sagen dir nicht ich werde
irgendwann Buchhalter sagen sie dir
definitiv nicht aber jetzt möchte ich
ganz am Ende von dir natürlich wissen
wenn du einen handwerkberuf gelernt
hättest was wir es gewesen eindeutig
Schreiner Tischler aus übrigens auch
ganz schön nach der Arbeit ne harte
Arbeit aber halt dieser dieser Geruch
von Holz und so weiter Zimmerei
allerdings auch also das ist nicht das
erste was man so sagt sie Mann und ich
freue mich ne ja ja total mich mich
fasziniert unfassbar wenn wenn wie von
von Geisterhand dann plötzlich so ein
Dachstuhl entsteht ja oder überhaupt so
eine ganze Konstruktion bei uns die
alten Bauernhöfe sind ja so aufgebaut du
hast sozusagen dass das Erdgeschoss das
ist dann häufig aus aus Stein oder
heutzutage Ziegel ja Mauerwerk auf jeden
Fall und dann darüber aber eine
komplette Holzkonstruktion das heißt die
komplette erste Etage und dann darüber
dieser Dachstuhl das ist alles eine
einzige große Holzkonstruktion um
während das entsteht hast du keine im
blassen Schimmer davon wie das
irgendwann alles zusammen gehen soll
funktioniert dann aber wie von
Geisterhand hält dann auch ist ist für
alle Eventualitäten auch also was
passiert wenn es dann warm wird im
Sommer ja Holz auch Holz dehnt sich dann
aus und so weiter die Fugen die du zu
berücksichtigen hast und so wie heizt
man dann wie wie was macht man besser
nicht und so was passiert im Winter was
passiert im Sommer das lebt ja alles das
arbeitet alles und das riecht so so
unvergleichlich schön deswegen mag ich
das so gerne so diese Idee des
nachhaltigen Bauens also machen viele
Bauern auch bei uns ja du hast dann ein
Stück weit und dann fängst du an aus
diesem Wald heraus eben das Holz zu
schlagen mit dem du dann einfach dein
Haus baust ja diese Unabhängigkeit die
daraus resultiert das ist ja auch
ehrlich gesagt auch so ein Stolz der da
mal drin ist in den Leuten deine Palio
liberale Seele
genau
was da was das angeht Küchenmesser
reicht mir
Richard das hat Spaß gemacht
ja Tschüss tschüss
[Musik]